hey guys what is the 9th of September my
name is Jess and here's all the things
that mattered in video games this week
[Music]
first up Ubisoft are offering yet
another free game as part of their 30th
anniversary celebration and this month
offering is the crew you can pick up the
crew for free on PC starting September
14 by heading to the UB 30 webpage and
following the prompts to your new free
game the current game on alpha is Rayman
Origins so you may want to head over
there now and pick that up before it
expires once you claim the game play
yours forever and there are two more
scheduled to arrive in the coming months
so stay tuned free-to-play MMO star trek
online has now arrived on Xbox one and
ps4 the game originally released with a
subscription-based model for PC in 2010
it contains over 130 story missions and
comes with the first two expansions as
well as major updates for console back
in May developer cryptic Studios
explained they'd made upgrades to the
game engine to enable improved visuals
and an enhanced user experience for
consoles it's always a good week when we
get Mass Effect Andromeda news though
yeah this has been a really good week I
always showed off new Andromeda gameplay
during Sony's PlayStation meeting and
confirmed it would support the upcoming
ps4 Pro which it was shown running on
the video shows the protagonist Ryder
exploring a cavernous area using a
jetpack and encountering alien devices
it was also confirmed that the game will
run at 30 frames per second on both ps4
Pro and the standard ps4 later this week
Bioware revealed that both the male and
female versions of Ryder will be in the
game no matter which you choose to play
as and that their siblings a new trailer
for Mass Effect Andromeda will be
released on November 7 next up is fifa
17 demo is coming next week ahead of the
game's release later this month lead
producer Gareth radar tells game reacted
that a demo for the game will be out on
September 13 no word yet on exactly what
will be included or what platforms it
will be available for but we'll keep you
posted he also revealed that FIFA 17 s
highest rated player is now Real
Madrid's Christian
Renaldo having bumped Lionel Messi down
from the top spot
FIFA 17 will arrive on ps4 Xbox one PC
360 and ps3 on September 27 it features
a new story mode which won't be in the
last generation versions of the game
finally pretty slow news week since a
knee just announced it they've got two
new ps4 models arriving before the years
out during the hotly anticipated
PlayStation meeting the company
announced a new thought is that smaller
ps4 call to the ps4 slim which has a 500
gigabyte hard drive and will run you 299
bucks it's throughout in most markets on
September 15 but the real star of the
show with the PlayStation neo whose
official name turned out to be the
PlayStation pro 2 out on November 10 the
$399 console will support 4k and HDR and
it features a one terabyte hard drive
double GPU power and a better CPU clock
speed there's been some contention over
the fact that it does not feature a
floor cam blu-ray player although it is
going to feature YouTube and Netflix
apps which will support HDR and 4k
streaming this week on site we talked
about our impressions of Mass Effect
Andromeda chat about how she is a force
for the road place and we have to wish
goodbye to the wonderful mr. Danny or
Dwyer
whose last days but is today so go say
something next to him all the luck and
love in the world's my dear friend Danny
you will be sorely missed
as for the rest of you be sure to have a
great weekend and the US will be taking
care of your news needs next week as
both of my producers have abandoned made
for glamorous overseas trips I will see
again soon
[Music]